[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Italy's election is still days away but
this felt like a victory rally a glimpse
of the future government
[Music]
at its heart Georgia Maloney who now
seems destined to become Italy's first
woman prime minister
her critics claim she is a far-right
demagogue but when we spoke it was an
accusation she vehemently denied
we are always there for the national
interests of Italy and we will show it
there is nobody all over the world who
needs to be afraid from us on
immigration though she is
unapologetically tough
I think that what Italy should do is to
stop uh boats leaving from Africa
within European me with the European
Mission I think the Europe all Europe
that has to defend I was uh borders uh
should talk with the governments of
North Africa
Maloney's party can trace its Origins
back to Fascism here in pradapio they
remember Mussolini born bred and buried
in this town and now an unsettling
attraction
people here told us they wanted a new
strong leader
governor
Maloney is no fascist and Italy has long
since moved on from the days of
Mussolini but if she wins the election
on Sunday then she'll change the country
for a start her Coalition will include
politicians from the far right but
secondly a Maloney government will
Embrace a new bold form of Italian
nationalism
and that will mean a plan to limit
migration already a divisive Topic in
this country
charity came here from Nigeria her
husband Alika was murdered on the street
earlier this year nobody came to help
no one
nobody decided nobody respond
that is what
I don't like see
there are a lot of people
there
no one no one nobody
Melania is seen his new radical and
intoxicating but Italian politics is a
brutal Arena where governments fall
often if she does win she'll have to act
fast
Adam Parsons Sky News Rome